welcome back to omics logic
transcriptomics where we discuss next
generation sequencing data analysis
methods and application to a variety of
different challenges in cancer
infectious diseases and biotechnology
this program is organized around six
major topics the tools and resources for
transcriptomic data analysis processing
next generation sequencing data
including pre-processing mapping and
quantification analysis normalization
and visualization of gene and isoform
expression an introduction to big data
mining machine learning and predictive
data analysis analysis of single cell
rnaseq data tissue specific expression
based on cell types and introduction to
hands-on project examples in a variety
of different fields
the goal of this session is to give you
an overview of ways you can open and
explore data in r
python and excel how to define the
headers and the numeric matrix that we
will analyze
how to identify genes samples and groups
how to use visualization to summarize
data and how to understand data
variability and general patterns that
you should expect to find in the table
of expression
before we go on let's briefly do a
review of quantification of mature mrnas
how to eliminate technical variation how
to find the best strategy to map your
reads onto the reference genome quantify
genes and isoforms in your data
and prepare the table of expression
all of these are covered in detail in
the online transcriptomics course that
you can find on learn
omixlogic.com there you will have a
detailed explanation of pre-processing
steps various strategies for mapping
and quantification of gene and isoform
table of expression you will also find
detailed tutorials on how to perform
differential gene expression analysis
and annotate your genes which is
something that we will briefly touch on
today in this session so how is mrna
abundance measured in biological samples
one way that it is done is through
reverse transcription pcr or rtpcr which
amplifies dna based on primer sequences
that frame the section of interest
the other way is to look at northern
blotting where an rna sample is digested
into fragments that are separated by
size in a gel using electrophoresis and
finally microarrays like northern bloods
are hybridization based methods that
provides highly detailed information
about the individual genes that have
been transcribed by putting those into a
chip
for next generation sequencing data
analysis what we need to know is how
data from the sequencer becomes
digitized so we talked a little bit
about different formats like fastq fasta
and gtf that are critical to understand
for processing the data and turning it
into a structured table of expression
the basic idea is to process short reads
that need to be cleaned up from any
technical variation mapped onto the
reference genome or transcriptome and
then quantified by counting the level of
expression and assigning a number to
each element that is placed into a table
called the table of expression
we have already done a few exercises
that you can perform on the tbi info
platform where color-coded buttons
represent methods of analysis starting
from pre-processing like truma-matic and
pcr clean onto different mapping
strategies like hysat2 cufflinks cuff
merge and bowtie and finally
quantification with rsem htc or sailfish
if you practice this several times you
will find that different combinations of
methods will provide you with different
pop-up screens where you can learn about
inputs and outputs for each step and
learn in detail about each method
finding publications where you can read
and understand what goes into every
single one of those buttons
one standard way that others have
described this process is through a
tuxedo protocol the tuxedo protocol
standardly involves such methods like
top hat which include bow tie and cuff
links the top hat protocol has been
around for a number of years since
2009 where the idea was to provide a
comprehensive process from raw reads to
expression levels differential gene
expression and even plots where you can
see differentially expressed genes
but since the time that top hat has been
published in 2009 a variety of different
methods for alignment quantification and
other methods have been generated and
now we see that there is a focus on
speed and accuracy that is represented
by methods like sailfish and callisto
which are called alignment free
strategies for quantification
these have been extensively benchmarked
and if you're interested in looking into
the various methods that are available
for mapping quantification and data
processing you should do a literature
review and you will find a number of
different papers that describe the
differences similarities in terms of
speed in terms of
the outputs and the inputs that these
methods provide and also how to use them
based on your research question but to
summarize all of these steps could be
organized into these three distinct
steps pre-processing mapping and
quantification and we color code them so
that it is easier to remember how these
different algorithms which are really
many are organized into logical steps
for processing rna-seq data
at the end of this process you will get
an expression table and so the obvious
question is how is this table organized
what do these numbers represent what can
i do with these numbers so that i can
find meaningful patterns and so today
we'll talk a little bit more about what
a meaningful pattern is how to look at
global patterns and individual patterns
and what can we learn about the nature
of rna-seq data from analyzing and
exploring the table
the table includes columns that are
organized by sample name so if you have
samples from different categories they
could be grouped and then you also have
genes and those genes are typically
encoded in one way or the other we'll
talk a little bit more about different
formats that you might expect to find in
your gene expression data the level of
expression varies by the type of
normalization technique that is applied
to derive an actual number as you can
imagine reeds don't stack up accurately
for a whole gene which could be fairly
long maybe thousands of nucleotides as
opposed to a reed that could only be a
hundred or a couple of hundred of
nucleotides long so how they stack up
could vary significantly across the
whole gene and to produce this number
the strategies vary so what we'll talk
about in today's session has to do with
the annotation the numbers that we have
in the gene expression and global
patterns as well as specific patterns
for genes and samples
in our examples we're using a table that
includes names like ansg
anst
ens musg and xlock
ensg stands for a human gene in the
ensemble format enst stands for human
transcript an ensemble id ans mas g
stands for mus musculus or mouse gene
and x-lock stands for an unannotated
transcript that was identified through
cufflinks and cuff merge to understand
what each individual gene looks like we
can plot the numbers in a bar plot and
so here you have a couple of examples of
a gene that has
some level of expression
in several different samples or across
all of the samples that we have in our
data
the annotation of genes started
immediately with the human genome
project the major goal was to identify
all of the genes that are present in the
human genome now there are approximately
22 500 genes in the human genome and
that number varies between different
organisms
they are recorded in a variety of
different databases
and according to those databases they
provide you with a unique id
the issue is that some ids are more
specific than others for example genes
can have a common name
the problem with the common name
is that sometimes the common name
can mean something
in a different format for example a
major challenge in excel is when the
gene name
like mar1
would be transformed into march 1st
automatically by excel without any
notification for you as the user
another issue is that sometimes multiple
transcripts could have the same gene
symbol
and so you might have repeated rows in
your table which will cause problems
when you try to work with such a table
in r or python
so that's why a number of different
strategies for naming genes has been
proposed the ensemble id includes the
name of the organism with an
identification number entres id only
provides you with a number each gene
will have multiple transcripts that are
typically annotated and those would be
enst
with a number for a human transcript and
you also have annotation of gene
function through a description
and gene ontology that tries to organize
all of this information about genes and
what they do in some kind of a logical
schema
the best way to find specific biological
examples of meaningful processing
annotation and interpretation of these
statistically significant patterns in
gene expression data is by look through
a number of example projects that we
have prepared and those include working
with cancer macrophages modeling cancer
precision medicine where we look at
different types of cell lines pdx tumor
microenvironment which is a project that
you will be introduced to in the
transcriptomics course but also we will
find other types of projects like
malaria infection potato drought
resistance or tcga liver cancer risk
through the cancer genome atlas
so let's talk about
analysis normalization and visualization
of gene and isoform expression
when you complete your pipeline you will
find several different outputs that are
typically going to be in a txt format so
you will find things like elements of
expression
normalized and filtered tables
as well as mapping and quality
statistics
each one of these could be used in a
variety of ways to help you understand
where do you have important patterns
that you can use to interpret and
validate your analysis results in terms
of quality and biological meaning one of
the next challenges when we complete the
pipeline is to open one of these files
let's say in excel in r or in python so
we'll briefly talk about how to do that
in all of these three environments as we
already saw the expression table
is a tab delimited txt file that
includes columns that are annotated in
the header which is the first row of
that table that provides us with sample
names typically those sample names will
be transformed to remind us of what are
the processing steps that were done to
that sample for example here you can see
additional words added to the name like
no adapters
no pcr and pe so no adapters and no pcr
means that they were processed with
pre-processing steps pcr clean and
trimmatic
p e stands for pair and reads
in the gene id you will find that there
is a name and then dot something and so
that dot something actually stands for a
transcript so you can forget about what
is after the dot because what we're
looking at is an expression of genes not
isoforms and the expression level is
typically going to be in fpkm format
which stands for fragments per kilobase
per million which is a standard way to
normalize your data when you have pair
and reads what it normalizes for is the
length of each gene because
statistically speaking the longer the
gene the more likely we will find reads
that fall
into that section on the genome and for
the total number of reads per million
that we have in a given sample so this
number is not going to be an integer
it's going to be a float so it's going
to have some kind of a point something
after that it's not a whole number and
so what why do we find this not whole
number the reason is because
we are actually using a technique to try
and distinguish
what is an actual abundance of reads
within the section that we call a gene
as opposed to some random noise where
reads could by chance align to some
section of the genome with
a method called rsem so using our sem
typically produces a normalized read
count or fpkm and tpm numbers that are
essentially not whole numbers not
integers so let's take a look at how we
can perform some of these basic steps in
microsoft excel to load our data into
microsoft excel
set up our data frame
use the numeric matrix matrix of
our data so that we can summarize it and
understand what's in it and how to plot
our data so that we can visually see
some of the patterns that appear in this
table when you open this data in excel
and i'm going to be using here an
example from excel on a mac if you want
to look up some of these methods in
excel on a pc i recommend looking on
youtube or on google there are many many
tutorials on how to do these things the
first way that we would like to look at
data is to summarize it using a box plot
now a box plot is an advanced so to say
statistical method of visualizing data
because it provides us not with a view
of each individual gene or each
individual number that we have which is
just too many we have over 6 000 genes
in this case but it tries to summarize
the sample statistics in a way that we
can compare overall distribution of our
data per sample so if you go into insert
menu
and then there find this little button
that looks like a histogram you will
open it and you will see that there are
two methods a histogram and a plot
called box and whisker
so let's take
the box and whisker option and you do
this after you select all of your data
and what you will find is a plot that
looks something like this what does this
mean this means that the majority of our
rows are found at the very bottom of the
y-axis so the x-axis here is samples the
y-axis is level of expression so the
majority of our data falls between zero
and maybe one thousand and then the
outliers range from about one thousand
to something like sixteen thousand so
first of all how do you manipulate this
specific chart in excel you can select
different aspects of this chart and open
the formatting panel where you will be
able to adjust different aspects of your
axes for example if you select the
x-axis you can change how wide or narrow
these are and you can also adjust how
individual samples look by assigning
them with a fill color and a color for
the border of that specific box and
whisker
but let's now speak a little bit about
box plots what essentially are box plots
showing
so typically a box plot looks something
like this here you can see this is
scaled data so you can see that the
middle of your y scale is zero
and for each one of your samples you
have a separate box
and so these
represent different statistical
properties of your data for example you
will find here the max value the minimum
value the upper and the lower quartile
as well as the median and sometimes you
will also find the mean so you can
include the mean in your box plot so
what does that tell us that tell us that
on average
we can see whether one sample has a
significantly higher level of expression
overall compared to others maybe it has
more outliers maybe it is more or less
normally distributed or skewed and now
we can kind of evaluate the quality of
our samples because overall we would
expect that conditions
essentially have some
comparable patterns within and the
difference between the conditions would
be also evident in some of these major
patterns that we can observe here now
unfortunately our data looks like this
and so we can't really see the majority
of our values right so we see only the
outliers
the way to address this is through log
scale transformation so essentially we
can transform not the data itself but
just the scale that we are presenting
our data in
and that will help us see the bulk of
our data
all of a sudden much more visible
because as you can remember logarithmic
scale brings the very high numbers that
we saw there up to sixteen thousand much
much closer to the lower numbers which
were all under one thousand right so we
have this sixteen time uh sixteen fold
higher numbers in the upper scale than
the lower scale and now we can see much
better what's happening overall
throughout the data
now how would we do this if we plot just
the fpm numbers we will get what you see
here on the left if we transform our
data to logarithmic scale you will see
that the data becomes much more expanded
and easier to see what it looks like now
to do that in excel all we need to do is
copy over all of the columns and insert
in each cell ln and in parentheses the
cell that we are using as the original
number plus one y plus one the logarithm
of one is 0 and so we don't have to
worry about adding that but we cannot
perform logarithm of 0 and so that's why
we have to have a minimum of 1 if we
have these zero numbers which you will
come across in your data now another
thing to remember is that each one of
these samples now we're not talking
about genes we're talking about samples
could be viewed
as a histogram that shows us the
distribution of each sample so
essentially a box plot is very similar
because it shows the distribution as
well but it kind of loses the actual
distribution pattern just showing us the
maximum minimum and the interquartile
range kind of not letting us see it bin
by bin as we can see in a histogram the
difference between the histogram and the
box plot is that in the histogram we can
ask the question whether our sample is
normally distributed now why is normal
distribution important for our
downstream analysis
many of the statistical tests that we
will use assume some kind of a normal
distribution and even if they don't they
will produce higher statistical power if
they do
now is it a must to transform your data
to normal distribution for you to be
able to perform downstream analysis no
it is not but for some cases it is going
to be very useful for example one of the
methods that we will use to investigate
general patterns in the data is called
principal component analysis and for
principal component analysis normalized
data and scale data is going to be
useful for your ability to interpret
what the
analysis actually is showing you
so let's take a look at how logarithmic
scale can be useful to transform our
data and that's what you see right here
this is your original data on the left
this is actually data after log scale
transformation now another thing to
remember when you perform this kind of
transformation is a couple of additional
methods of normalization that are
typically used
what are these methods
one important thing to remember is that
we have
some level of very low expressed genes
you can see here on the right between
zero and 0.23
and all the way up until maybe 2 or 3 or
4 or even 5 so it will be very difficult
to find statistically significant
differences within these low expressed
genes because we have low expressed
genes
in different samples that have
different distributions it's useful to
find a method that can normalize
distribution across our samples so that
we can make them more comparable to each
other and so one way to do that is
called quantile normalization
essentially what quantile normalization
does is it
makes the samples similarly distributed
and aligned at the mean well we can take
two samples
and assume that they represent the exact
same condition our overall expectation
would be
that a gene in one sample from the same
condition and another sample from
another condition would be very
comparable so we transform the data
as opposed to just changing the scale
but we're essentially working with the
distribution and the mean aligning them
to each other
rather than
working individually with each sample
so on the platform you will also find
the quantile normalization option
and as you can see after quantile
normalization the data becomes much more
comparable to each other
one of the questions for quantile
normalization is a threshold what is a
threshold that we should use when we
perform quantum normalization the answer
to that question is really dependent on
your data sets so
investigating your data and
understanding the overall pattern is
going to be important for you to choose
that threshold correctly as a standard
option you can use 1000 for non-log
scale or 5 for scale and this is of
course a rule of thumb but you should
really look into your data to find a
threshold that you should
use for your specific data set
in this case we can look at our data
distribution
try to make it more
normal-like by performing log scaling
and filtering of low express genes and
then thinking about where is the signal
in our data and the signal in the data
is going to be most significant for more
highly expressed genes that are
going to be having the most effect on
the condition
so in the phenotype
and then taking the rest of the data
underneath that underneath that
threshold and assuming that the majority
of that data represents some normal
biological function
and because it is normal biological
function that is going to be quite
similar between all of the samples that
we have we can now normalize that with
quantile normalization without touching
anything above
that threshold so the threshold means
that everything under that threshold is
going to be quantum normalized
everything above will be left exactly
the same like we have it on the platform
you will also find that you have several
options
and those options include logarithmic
scale and when you perform this
transformation you will see how it
changes the way that you evaluate
differences between genes so here's an
example of a gene
en is g123416
and you can see it before and after
quantile normalization and log scale
transformation
so first of all when we look at it
before any kind of transformation you
can see that the top expression is in
the first sample
and that sample is an er positive sample
an expression is very close to 5 000.
none of the genes really come close to
that and our
expectation just by looking at this with
our eyes is that er positive samples
have a higher overall expression
compared to triple negative
but when we think about how high it is
and how much higher overall compared to
the other types of samples what we need
to remember is that the data is not
normalized so it is likely to be
affected by issues like
total number of reads in each sample
that we have
maybe the quality of mapping so which
proportion of reads was mapped to the
reference genome and all kinds of other
technical issues that we have
less control over after quantum
normalization with a threshold of five
we can see that the comparison now is
much more clear
overall there is not such a statistical
difference between these two conditions
now another way to check this is again
to follow the same assumption that our
individual samples in a group of samples
should be comparable to each other so if
they are comparable to each other that
means that we can plot one of them on
the x-axis and another one on the y-axis
and if we draw a parallel line
that line represents
exact
similarity between these samples in
terms of levels of gene expression so if
we plot it without normalization
and without log scaling you can see that
it's very difficult to see that these
samples actually do represent the same
condition
after this transformation you can see
that it is much more clear that in in
fact they do
have a relationship and they are quite
similar to each other so that's another
way to check how your data changed after
these transformations now let's take a
look at how we can perform some of these
steps in r and r studio so we'll talk
about again loading data
setting up a data frame working with the
matrices and plotting the data and all
of these are going to be very useful for
you to do
independently we have some practice
exercises that you can go through and
see how they are done in terms of syntax
and in terms of application to different
formats here we have a process for
working with this data in r so exactly
how to do this you can read about and
practice in the tutorial online but i'll
just briefly explain some of the things
that you need to remember as you get
started in r now i'm going to skip
all of the standard introductions about
setting up r installing the different
packages all of that is going to be very
specific to your environment how it's
set up
what kind of operating system you have
uh different versions and and where you
download things from and we try to cover
that in the introductory course in r so
i welcome you to go and see all of those
explanations there but here i'll just
briefly focus on the concepts and the
syntax that you need to keep in mind as
you go through these exercises r is an
object-oriented language anything like a
variable a plot or a table of data is
stored as an object that object has
properties and once it is loaded in the
proper format
we can do actions
or functions
on that object so the first thing that
we need to do is we need to load our
data
and put it into an object
to do that we use the equal sign or as
people use an r
sign that you see right here
which is
this less sign and the dash okay so
these are equivalent to each other
to load the table you have to understand
what the table format is
the format could be a txt and if it is a
txt it has a separator in between your
columns
so that separator could be a tab
could be a comma
could be a dot
underscore space right it could be a
number of different things so that's why
when you use the function read table
you have to also specify how is it going
to be separated
and
where is it loaded from is also an
important thing to remember so you can
either provide a link like an http link
where the table is stored or you can
upload the data on your computer and
then you have to provide it with a path
in our studio on your computer you would
typically set a working directory so
that you don't have to write the full
path to your uh to the names of your
files you can just put the name of the
file if it is within the main working
directory that would be sufficient for
you to be loading the data from there if
your data is in a comma separated value
format csv format you can use
read.csv
if it is in excel
you can say
there is a package to read
excel files and so you can load that
package and then read the data from an
excel specifying which sheet in your
excel file you would like to use the
data could be stored as a data frame
matrix
a list
or an array a data frame is essentially
a table like an excel table where you
have your strings
as row names and column names
and the rest of the data could be
numeric integers or floats
a matrix
is just the numeric portion of that data
so you could store
the names of your columns and the names
of your genes let's say as a list
you can then store your full data frame
your full table as a data frame
you can separate the portion of the data
frame and turn it into a matrix
and having it in a matrix allows you to
perform
summary statistics and
visualize the data for numeric type of
statistical representations like
histograms and box plots
lists and arrays are going to be useful
because often times you need to remember
different things and use them later on
down the road when you
load your data let's say you call your
data frame df
or you can call it gene expression or
any name that you would like
once it is an object you can also
transform it into a matrix by simply
saying as dot matrix and in parentheses
the name of your data frame
once you have that data frame you can
calculate the mean
or produce a summary for your whole data
frame and understand differences between
different elements by doing by looking
at the summary instead of the actual
data that you have
how to visualize the data
inside the same tutorial you will find
detailed explanations on how to plot box
plots that we just discussed today
bar plots which are going to be useful
for visualizing genes across samples for
example
scatter plots where you can compare a
couple of samples
and how they relate to each other
or heat maps where heat maps are most
useful for visualizing a small portion
of genes maybe 20 or 50 or 100 to view
how
they relate to each other based on gene
expression patterns and so all of these
are going to be provided in the
exercises for base which is the basic
functionality of r but also in ggplot a
popular visualization package for r
now all of the same things could be done
in python the difference between python
and r primarily is that python does take
a little bit longer to install and set
up
you do have some key libraries that we
will talk about here where you would
have to find different types of
functionality the syntax is a little bit
different but after a little bit of
practice in both languages it will be
fairly simple for you to start working
with your data in either one deciding on
each one i think is really beneficial
for those of you that will be
working
with standard statistical methods and
quick outputs that are publication ready
that's typically going to be easier and
are
python is going to be a little bit more
efficient
probably
more
appropriate for those of you that are
going to be working with big data
machine learning and things like that
even though both are possible in either
language
in python there are two major libraries
to work with data numpy and pandas numpy
is essentially a series of functions
that are designed to work with matrices
with numbers
and
pandas is more specific to working with
data frames of course pandas leverages
the numpy library to perform many of the
analytical
steps that we will talk about today now
on the portal again you have a way to
practice some of the syntax it's
important to get started to import the
libraries in python
libraries are loaded
as
objects and then from those objects you
can do a path to a specific function
but it also provides you with some steps
and work with some of those
data frame aspects like finding specific
columns rows
but essentially as you go through the
tutorial you will see that it is very
similar to r even though some of the
syntax is going to be different
so i'm going to use a google collab
notebook as you can see i already wrote
here importing packages and i'm
importing pandas and spd and numpy as np
my data is going to be stored on github
so i'm going to take a link
and i'm going to load this data so i'm
going to call this variable gene
expression
equals
and now i need to say pd because it's a
function of pandas and i'm going to say
read
table
now in parentheses i'm going to paste
the link to the data
to preview the data i can load only the
head only the first several rows of this
data
now i can see that i have
my
jeans
and the header row is right here with
all of my numbers
inside of these cells
i can also set the index to be the id so
that this is not included in the numeric
part of my data to do that i have to say
gene expression index
equals to
gene
expression
and the column name is id
so here
i have id
now if i preview it again
we will see that now the name of each
gene is stored in a separate special
column called id
since now i have another column inside
the data i need to remove it from the
actual dataset
i can do that
using
a command called drop
so here i need to say that it equals to
the same
but i'm going to drop
a column called id so to do that i need
to specify
here id
and mention that the axis
equals one
which would mean
the call
and again i can say
gene expression
so now my data is ready for analysis
gene expression
and now i can specify the location
specifically naming let's take the first
gene that we have
and after that i just need to say plot
dot bar
and here we have
the bar plot for this particular gene we
can also specify in here to give it a
title
and now we know that this is the plot
for this specific gene across our
samples
to make a box plot is also easy
gene expression
and here we have our box plot as you can
see the titles of each sample are not
rotated correctly so i can just add in
here ra
equals 90.
and this is our raw data for the gene
expression box plot across samples
data to logarithmic scale all we have to
do is say gene
expression
log
equals
numpy
dot log
and now use gene
expression
plus
1.
to visualize as a box plot we simply
take gene
expression
log
box plot
and now we can see what this data looks
like in logarithmic scale
so what are some of the conclusions from
today's session you saw today how to
take the table of expression and start
working with it in excel r and python
you should be able to understand the
difference between data frames matrices
lists and arrays you should be able to
know how to summarize and visualize your
data using box plots histograms bar
plots
and even heat maps after a little bit of
practice and you can start testing some
of the assumptions that you might have
about your data for example how
comparable are different samples how are
they different overall and how maybe
some specific patterns could be found in
the data you will also see some of the
steps to scale and transform data and i
do want to remind you that the bulk of
these methods are described in very
specific details in the online tutorial
so really i encourage you to go through
those tutorials and do some practice as
well
that's it for today in our next session
we will talk about principal component
analysis